a prevailing theory for nearly two
decades has many women leery of using
hormone replacement therapy as they age
critics believed HRT dramatically
increased the risk of breast cancer
Denise Valdez tells us how opinions have
evolved in this buddy check report
a lot has changed since that Women's
Health Initiative study it turns out the
issue is not quite as black and white as
we once thought I remember that day that
all of a sudden it was like a wall came
down Dr Mary Claire Haber is an
accomplished and respected OB GYN she
reflects on a date more than 20 years
ago that tainted hormone replacement
therapy as too risky we are stopping
this trial it is too dangerous to take
hormone replacement therapy it is going
to give you cancer the 2002 study from
the Women's Health Initiative set shock
waves through the health care industry
since then much of the study's findings
have been walked back and now 20 years
later new research and improved
medications suggest hormone replacement
therapy is not as threatening as
previously suggested add about a 30
percent decrease risk of breast cancer
overall and women with estrogen and
progestin did have a slight increased
risk
and it went from about 3.2 percent to
about 3.8 percent it's different for
every patient including factors like the
type of HRT the dosage your age when you
start taking it and how long you use it
Dr Haber specializes in treating
perimenopausal and menopausal women
through her practice her book I do
prescribe testosterone for my patients
and extended through social media she
encourages women to gauge their risk
tolerance and family history with the
health benefits we are no longer blanket
pulling women off those who are keeping
up with the latest studies pulling women
off at a certain age and saying it's too
dangerous at this point especially if
she's done well the American Cancer
Society says estrogen only HRT is not
linked to a higher risk of breast cancer
so the benefits of it such as quality of
life and protection of bone health can
really outweigh the risk for certain
women so it's really best to educate
yourself and talk with your doctor to
decide what's right for you for Buddy
check I'm Denise Valdez back to you